and now to yvaldi texas and the fiery
public response to a report highlighting
failures in the police response to that
school shooting that killed 19 young
children and two of their teachers
people filled the room at last night's
school district meeting demanding that
officials explain those mistakes and
take responsibility lydia luciano was in
uvalde where she attended that meeting
leo good morning i saw one parent say
every time we hear something it
re-triggers us it like opens the pain up
all over again and what they heard
yesterday was horrendous
good morning to you that's right galen
for
good morning for many of those parents i
talked to and i heard from it was the
first school board meeting that they
attended they say they had to do it this
community is in shock that school police
chief pete arredondo is still on
administrative leave they want him fired
and they also called for the
superintendent to step down this
community is ready for change and they
are angry
you saw the videos it's out there and
now we all know
the truth
that truth spelled out an excruciating
detail in a damning report by state
lawmakers brought an outraged community
to monday's uvalde school district
meeting what are you going to do to make
sure i don't have to wait 77 minutes
bleeding out on my classroom floor just
like my little sister did raw grief fear
and skepticism including among yuvaldi's
youngest like melee taylor i don't want
to go to your guys school if they don't
have protection the superintendent
outlined changes the district is making
to protect students from tightening
school access points and adding more
security cameras to hiring additional
police officers but many said the
precautions are too little too late
you hired trash
that's not right
i lost a loved one right here the
state's investigation found that school
administrators did not adequately
prepare for the risk of an armed
intruder pointing to faulty locks and
relaxed security policies that gave the
attacker unimpeded access to enter the
classrooms you're the superintendent
your top dog correct yes so you should
know what's going on in your schools
correct
why don't you
the report also concluded that the
gunman likely murdered most of his
victims before any responders set foot
in the building and that others may have
survived if police hadn't assembled in a
hallway waiting to act for an additional
73 minutes we feel like most of these
meetings are pointless
this was the first school board meeting
for jose flores senior and cynthia
herrera since their ten-year-old jose
flores was killed two days after the
shooting we spoke with a step-sister
nine-year-old survivor andrea
the parents say andreas not returning to
school until they see significant change
i'm scared
that it just might happen again
and is it hard having to see all these
officers around well i don't even focus
on that
everybody who was recorded in that video
and ran the other way they all need to
be fired
there's no point of having them there
superintendent hal harrell stood by the
move to put redondo on leave he said the
board will use the findings from the
committee investigating the shooting
from those legislators to make a final
decision they did not say when that
decision will come tony
all right lily thank you very much yeah
part of the frustration i think for
these families is it's been so difficult
to get a a straight answer when you when
you think about what happened in the
beginning that big news conference with
the governor and all the officials
praising the work that the law
enforcement officers had done and then
to see on tape that none of that was
true i know it's just heartbreaking and
very frustrating especially for the
families who are still demanding
accountability and so far nothing has
happened yeah and this information
wouldn't have come out without the
reporting exactly folks like lily and
other reporters on the ground exactly
right